ايه فعلا في الاولها لقيت ناس بتحاربني
جامد قوي مش عايزين نشتغل مش عايزين اكل
العيش مش عايزين يديني الدفع لا عايزين
نبقى منكسره كده مذلوله لا بس يكون عندك
اراده يكون عندك هم كده انك تبقي قويه
بقابل ناس كويسه جدا مقابل اللي يطبطب علي
بيقابل اللي يشتمني بقابل واحد ممكن يكون
راكب جنبي يقعد يتريق يقعد يهزر همم عنده
حاله يعني اللي قاعد عنده حاله ظهور طب
انت هتموتينا همم طب انت انت اللي هتسوقي
بجد طب انت اللي هتطلعي بنا انت تعرفي
تسوقي انا ساعات زبون بيفتح العربيه لان
واحده ست بعياله ينزل من العربيه لا لا
انزلي دي هتموتنا همم مش عارفه ايه
والكلام ده اقابل كان نفسي حاجه في الدنيا
دي والحمد لله اتجوزت وربنا كرمني بثلاث
ايام وما فيش نصيب وطلقه وخلاص بقى حفرت
حفرت مع الناس والناس حرب بس حرب بادب
واحترام مش بقله ادب
[موسيقى]